491 1840 exactement c'est le nombre de
fichiers de patients français qui ont
été volés et diffusée sur internet
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont révélé nos
confrères de libération
dans chacun de ces fichiers des
informations ultra sensibles comme le
nom des patients leurs coordonnées leurs
numéros de sécurité sociale et même pour
certains des annotations sur leur état
de santé
fait étonnant ces données ont été mises
en ligne gratuitement
c'est un fichier à valeurs fortes avec
des noms des adresses des coordonnées
des numéros de sécurité sociale
en plus de la fuite en elle-même le fait
que ces informations étaient des mises
en ligne gratuitement et extrêmement
perturbant et inquiétant selon le site
de vérification des faits de libération
tchèque news toutes ces données
appartiendrait à une trentaine de
laboratoires et correspondrait à des
prélèvements médicaux réalisés entre
2015 et 2020 durant cette période les
laboratoires concernés par ce larcin
aurait utilisé le même logiciel de
saisie de données médicales
nous n'avons aucune certitude quant au
fait que ce soit uniquement un logiciel
daedalus france qui est en cause dans
cette affaire
nous avons mis en place une cellule de
crise car nous prenons cela au sérieux
et nous allons travailler en partenariat
avec nos clients pour comprendre ce
qu'il s'est passé
d'après damien bancal auteur du blog
zataz première à avoir identifié cette
gigantesque fuite
une dispute entre pirate informatique
aurait déclenché la publication de ces
fichiers médicaux
toujours est il qu outre le vol et la
violation du caractère ô combien privée
de ces données les patients présents
dans ce fichier peuvent devenir des
cibles pour les pirates informatiques
les personnes y figurant sont des cibles
de choix pour du phishing personnalisé
en voie de faux messages ou de faux
documents pour récupérer des
informations personnelles ou de l'argent
d'éventuels pirates disposent désormais
de leur numéro de sécurité sociale du
nom de leur médecin prescripteur de la
date de leur examen du nom du
laboratoire ou encore dans certains cas
d'informations médicales
ajoutez à cela le risque du
passion d'identité vous obtenez un
cocktail explosif pour des gens mal
intentionnés
ces dernières semaines les
établissements liés à la santé sont
devenus des cibles privilégiées pour les
pirates informatiques
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information révèle que depuis
le début de l'année une attaque par
semaine et portées contre un hôpital
français